Hey what's going on guys we are back in this video
we are experimenting with bottled oxygen and a can of pringles
now before we jump into this crazy mad science
i've noticed a lot of comments about how dirty my lab jacket has become
and in my opinion a dirty lab jacket is just a token of how much knowledge and experience we've been able to gain
but to answer your requests; lets go ahead and get that changed
*claps*
and they we have it! problem solved! lets dive right in.
now you probably remember a few videos ago we took a propane bottle, snipped the tip, and turned it upside down to extract liquid propane.
do you think the same method will work with a bottle of oxygen?
could we extract liquid oxygen?
so quick update guys i've got my modified nozzle off the propane torch, but when we try adding it to the oxygen..
..the threads dont match which means we can't screw it on and we can't use it to extract the oxygen
so we are going to have to try something a little bit different
and if you look down the mouth of the bottle you can see there's a little button in there
and if you use something small enough and press that button down, you get the oxygen to release
*oxygen makes spurt noise*
the other thing that i notice is; as we shake the bottle around I cant hear any liquid sloshing around
which doesnt give me much confidence there's much in this bottle at all
and if we look at the side of the bottle you can see its only 1.4 ounces,, which really isn't alot
so why than are these bottles of oxygen 11 dollars! 11 dollars for an ounce and a half!
cmon guys
flip these things over and see what we
can get out
all right our wrenches set in position
our bottles upside down theoretically we
release the gas and if it cools down
enough we should get liquid oxygen here
we go
oh my gosh there we go ten seconds my
pliers are barely even frosted my allen
wrench has a little bit of frost on it
but there was absolutely no liquid so
this thing is completely empty now I can
press that button and it's completely
depressurize there's no more oxygen ten
seconds and nothing's satisfying about
that that was $11 completely vaporized
so for our next experiment what would
happen if we soaked one of these bottles
in liquid nitrogen first if we were to
bring the temperature down so cold and
bring the oxygen that's already in there
down to a liquid perhaps then we could
get it to drip out see if it works
alright it's time to chill it up let's
get this canister completely submerged
here we go I'm just going to do this
nice and slowly because they don't want
that nitrogen to boil out the top look
at the way it jumps it's jumping like a
good two inches high there from all the
heat that is extracting I'm listening
the container and I can hear things
contracting in there I can hear it
cooling down I love these little drops
of nitrogen this spit out a little smoke
trails we're getting the boil that's a
good sign
the storm before the calm
and we just hit the bottom as far down
as I can go right there the boiling
nitrogen makes really cool noise I just
love the way this down alright so we are
completely submerged we're just going to
chill here for about 30-40 second and
right there you can see the nitrogen is
gone relatively calm which means most of
the heats been extracted so go ahead and
make your predictions below now that our
oxygen is cooled down to the temperature
of liquid nitrogen if I turn it upside
down and press the button will we in
fact extract liquid oxygen check this
out the canisters changed color it used
to be like a really bright red and now
it's more like an orange that's kind of
interesting it's pretty stark contrast
in the color there all right moment of
truth I'm not really sure how to do this
I've just got a death grip with my
pliers around the neck here I'm going to
pull it out use the allen wrench to get
up there and press the button and we'll
see if we can get any oxygen out that
looks really cold
very very cool drip off the nitrogen
press the button and here's what we get
it's actually so cold right now the
button is barely even releasing I do see
some liquid dropping out there do you
see that we just have a couple little
drops yeah there it is look at that we
are in fact getting liquid oxygen not
much to hold it up here maybe you could
see it better I think that's about all
we're going to get this bottle is
completely empty now but check it out we
did it managed to get a little bit of
liquid oxygen come look at this right
down there in the bottom boiling away is
a little bit of what I think is liquid
oxygen
and it's gone okay so that was well
anti-climatic so yes apparently
theoretically it is possible to extract
liquid oxygen from one of these
canisters
however for eleven dollars of oxygen and
the cost of liquid nitrogen we got such
a little amount I don't even know if
that was worth it so for this last
experiment I'm going to show you the
method that I love to use the most for
making liquid oxygen because it's very
cheap very economical you certainly get
a lot more than an ounce and a half so
what exactly do we need to generate
liquid oxygen well surprisingly the only
materials were going to need are a
canister of liquid nitrogen and some
styrofoam cups now go ahead and grab
yourself a Styrofoam cup in this case
I'm using eight just to speed the
process we're going to lay them all out
across the counter now that we got our
styrofoam laid out on the counter we're
going to take our liquid nitrogen and
fill each of them up individually to the
top now we're pretty much just going to
step back and let them sit for 25
minutes
styrofoam axor is a really good
insulator so we don't lose nearly as
much nitrogen filling these up as we
would with any other container and the
best part of this nitrogen is this all
homemade there we go all of our
styrofoam cups are completely filled up
to the brim they couldn't go anymore
they be able to flowing all we have to
do at this point now is simply step back
and let them sit for about 25 minutes
quick update guys it has been an hour
we've been letting this nitrogen just
sit here what's been happening it has
been taking the oxygen out of the air
and condensing it and that oxygen is
dripped down to the bottom and stayed
there until the nitrogen boiled off you
can see each of these containers have
reduced to about 1/8 of their original
volume and if you look really closely
you'll notice that the liquid has turned
blue that blue liquid my friends is
liquid oxygen and now if we take all
eight of these cups and dump them
together we get one full styrofoam cup
of liquid oxygen very very cool stuff
the other thing that's really
interesting is how frosty these cups get
you can see all the different layers
where they've actually taken the
moisture in the atmosphere and condenser
through the side watch this if I just
tap these cup gently all the snow falls
off
fun pretty pretty blue oxygen guys look
how beautiful that is not only do we
have a full cup of liquid oxygen we
actually have a little bit left over as
well it's almost like what we would hope
to see if we added blue food coloring
the liquid nitrogen and it actually
worked but this here is very natural
oxygen is liquid state is blue and it's
also paramagnetic check this out we take
something like a strong neodymium magnet
and hold it near the liquid look what
happens the liquid jumps up onto the
magnet and six
how crazy is that liquid oxygen responds
to a magnet at least until it burns off
quite a bit of it on there I can't get
it off it's stuck
that's cool now I don't have to mention
guys that liquid oxygen unlike liquid
nitrogen is a very very volatile
substance if it comes in contact with a
fuel liquid nitrogen is not flammable it
puts out fires but if you add a fuel to
liquid oxygen and light it off the
results can be explosive so here's what
I'm thinking guys what do you think
would happen if we popped a pack of
Pringles so if one of the chips in
liquid oxygen and then let it off shall
we find out all right so we're going to
move our oxygen over here we're going to
dip this chip until it gets very very
cold and what I'm hoping is happening is
it's infusing with oxygen I've never
tried this before so I'm not really sure
what to expect all right that should be
enough see if I can fish that out not
easy there we go
all right got my flame going let's light
it off
not nearly as fat as I was expecting
Oh and now look it stopped burning it
was kind of like sizzling and popping
and going quite quickly and now it's
slowing down let's pour a little bit of
oxygen on it oh yeah we can get it to
reignite look at that slide that ship
right toward the oxygen Wow
you see that when the oxygen makes
contact it almost explode every time it
touches
look at those oxygen here it's just
going around it it's got the same
similar properties to liquid nitrogen
delayed in the frost effect what happens
if I cap it it goes into a million
pieces
isn't these chips just randomly spark up
that's cool all right let's try that
again let's get one of these chips
soaking but the oxygen burns off a
little too quickly so what I'm going to
do is pour a little bit of oxygen into
the plate as well before we actually let
it off okay there's our chip we're going
to set that right there and let it off
more oxygen
oh yes that's very vigorous
oh wow
look at all these pieces of Pringle
floating around you got black blobs of
Kringle filling the entire airspace
above my head that's kind of nasty and
finally let's just do the Styrofoam cup
itself there goes oh my goodness look at
the ceiling oh that was a bad idea
there you have a guys that was
incredible and now you know how to use
liquid nitrogen and styrofoam cups to
make liquid oxygen right out of the air
we start off filling up eight cups with
liquid nitrogen right to the top then
let them sit for about an hour until all
the nitrogen had boiled off but in the
process of the nitrogen boiling off the
oxygen in the atmosphere condensed and
was sucked into the cups and when we
mixed all eight of those cups together
we had a cup overflowing of blue liquid
oxygen which apparently is paramagnetic
just keep in mind that liquid oxygen can
be very very dangerous stuff and if it
catches anything on fire you can make a
terrible mess thanks for joining me for
this experiment guys I'll be looking for
you the next one talk to you then that
was unexpected that got frost you didn't
it whoo the cryo container freezing my
fingers looks very cool
Outro